ich begrüße jetzt ganz herzlich
Professor Andreas Heinemann grüner
konfliktforscher und
Politikwissenschaftler in Bonn und auch
ein ausgewiesener
osteuropa-experte herzlich willkommen
und danke dass Sie uns hier durch den
Vormittag mit begleiten wollen wir haben
es ganz kurz eben im Beitrag schon mit
angerissen was erwartet uns denn ihrer
Meinung nach da in wenigen Minuten in
Moskau
es geht um eine Bilanz der sogenannten
spezialoperation seit Februar diesen
Jahres was ist erreicht worden es geht
darum die Bevölkerung für einen längeren
Krieg auch in 2023 vorzubereiten vor
allen Dingen auch auf eine
Kriegswirtschaft die Wirtschaft
vorzubereiten die Regionen müssen
vorbereitet werden moralisch auf die ja
Kosten die das für die Bevölkerung auch
mit sich bringt insofern werden da auch
die Gouverneure und die
Verwaltungsbeamten eingestimmt also
letztlich geht es darum anzuerkennen
diese spezialoperation kann nicht zu
einem schnellen Ende mehr kommen sondern
wir müssen uns auf einen langen Krieg
einstellen und dafür müssen alle Kräfte
mobilisiert werden
wenn wir mal bei den Begrifflichkeiten
mal anfangen bisher ist es ja noch immer
eine sonderoperation in Russland und ist
ja unter Strafe gestellt von einem Krieg
zu sprechen glauben Sie dass sich das
möglicherweise noch mal ändert eventuell
das Wording dass wir vielleicht heute
schon da auch mit einem anderen Begriff
vielleicht den betriebsbegriff
konfrontiert werden
davon gehe ich eher nicht aus dass sie
jetzt nachdem sie zehn Jahre zehn Monate
lang abgestritten haben das ist ein
Krieg ist jetzt plötzlich das ändern
sondern sie müssen irgendwie deutlich
machen was sind eigentlich angesichts
der desaströsen Lage die neuen
Kriegsziele das heißt
das Militär aber auch die Bevölkerung
die
Verwaltungsbeamten die Politiker in den
Regionen die wollen alle wissen worauf
müssen wir uns jetzt eigentlich
einstellen nachdem die ursprünglich
deklarierten Ziele nicht erreichbar sind
ob das geht also in an Detail jetzt
eigentlich noch mal
spezifiziert wird weiß ich nicht ich
vermute dass er gesagt wird wir wollen
letztlich nur die Anerkennung der
formell annektierten Gebiete und dass
die Ukraine akzeptiert was wir sozusagen
als Teil der Russischen Föderation
deklariert haben
hat denn Vladimir Putin und sein
Verteidigungsminister Schau gut
überhaupt denn noch militärische
Operationsmöglichkeiten noch überhaupt
militärische Optionen
ja sie sind mit ihrer Offensive seit
August diesen Jahres gestoppt insofern
ist das ein abnutzungskrieg auf der
anderen Seite können Sie die Kampfzone
wieder erheblich ausweiten und damit
auch
ukrainische Kräfte binden die eben
erfolgreich waren weil sie sich an
bestimmten Stellen seit Sommer sozusagen
konzentrieren konnten also wenn man die
russische Front aufmacht und von da
Angriffe wieder auf Kiel fliegt dann
würde das also auch dazu führen dass die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte über eine
wesentlich längere Front sich
verteidigen müssen sie können auch
Sommer die mobilisierten Soldaten
durchaus einsetzen das ist so im
September von manchen Experten
heruntergespielt worden das wäre ja
vollkommen ineffektiv das habe ich von
Anfang an so ein bisschen als als
vergeben oder falschen Optimismus
eingeschätzt also russland hat
erhebliche mobilis
sie laufen natürlich ein bisschen aus
Munition und auch auch Bewaffnung aus
aber Sie können auch die
Kriegswirtschaft anwerfen und sagen
alles für die Front das ist eine
Priorität
also ich halte Russland jetzt hier von
den Reserven die es mobilisieren kann
noch nicht am Ende der Fahnenstange
vielleicht noch mal für die
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer auch noch
mal die sich jetzt erst zugeschaltet
haben ganz wichtig wir warten ja auf
eine Pressekonferenz von Wladimir Putin
bzw seinem Verteidigungsminister Scholl
GU in Moskau die ist für 11 Uhr dort
unserer Zeit angekündigt und dort sollen
dann eben auch die militärischen
Optionen und Ziele für 20 23 hier
vorgestellt werden natürlich sicherlich
im Hinblick auf die Ukraine gehen wir
mal zum einem weiteren Nachbarn der an
diesem konfliktiert ja direkt
geographisch gelegen ist das ist ja Bela
Ruß da gab es ja einen Besuch den ersten
glaube ich hier seit drei Jahren das
Wladimir Putin seinen Amtskollegen den
Präsidenten von Belarus Lukaschenko
besucht hat
sehen sie da irgendwelche Fortschritte
Ergebnisse dass es doch Russland gelingt
Belarus in den Krieg mit hineinzuziehen
das wäre innenpolitisch im Belarus
erheblich
mit Spannung verbunden weil die direkte
Beteiligung der Russen an dem Krieg
gegen die Ukraine in hohem Maße und
populär wäre auf der anderen Seite kann
natürlich Belarus das eigene Territorium
für russische Angriffe zur Verfügung
stellen es sind ja auch schon
Raketenangriffe von
Erfolg an der Vergangenheit man könnte
da auch Flughäfen nutzen und damit sagen
die Ukraine erzwingen Teile an die
russische Front zu schicken also
insofern halte ich das nicht für
ausgeschlossen umgekehrt hat es auch
Trainings von dieser
Gruppe Wagner in Keller Russ gegeben das
heißt man kann auch mit sozusagen
irregulären bewaffneten Gruppen von
Bella Russ aus operieren
und die belarussische Grenze ist
natürlich wesentlich dich da ein Kiew
dran das heißt also man
im Moment werden viele von den Drohnen
die Russland abschießt durchaus
abgefangen von der Luftabwehr ob schon
natürlich viele auch noch die
ukrainische Hauptstadt erreichen aber
wenn das von Belarus aus geschehen würde
dann wäre die Möglichkeit den Luftraum
über Kiew zu verteidigen noch wesentlich
eingeschränkter
die Rede die wir erwarten von Vladimir
Putin bzw seinem Verteidigungsminister
zu dem militärischen Ausblick für
Russland fürs kommende Jahr ist die eine
Sache aber es gibt ja noch ein paar
andere Schauplätze der Weltpolitik die
alle sich rund um die Ukraine drehen da
würde ich jetzt einmal noch mal den
Besuch von Medvedev stellvertretender
Vorsitzender des nationalen
Sicherheitsrates in Russland Hervorheben
der hat sich nämlich mit dem
chinesischen Präsidenten Ski getroffen
und dort auch eine längere Unterredung
geführt
wie werden sie dort die Signale die nach
diesem Gespräch gekommen sind also sie
hat z.B noch mal betont er erwartet dass
alle Beteiligten am Ukraine Konflikt
sich zurückhaltend Mahnung an Russland
oder Mahnung an die USA
also es ist eine Mahnung natürlich dass
man den Krieg nicht ausweitet auf
Atomwaffen und das China überhaupt kein
Interesse daran hat dass es hier zu
einer globalen Eskalation kommt und das
haben sie auch deutlich gesagt also aber
Putin und mit weniger für sollen mit
ihren Drogen Atomwaffen einzusetzen
damit sollen sie aufhören da gibt es
auch eine Einigkeit jetzt auch mit der
westlichen Politik auf der chinesischen
Seite auf der anderen Seite ist
natürlich Russland interessiert daran
die Sanktionen mit chinesischer Hilfe
umgehen zu können das heißt also Chips
zu bekommen die für ihre eigene
Produktion nötig sind sie müssen ja
schon eigentlich Technik kannibalisieren
um um sozusagen elementare Computer da
auch auf
Operationen aufrecht erhalten zu können
also das ist das eine zweitens
finanzamtionen mit chinesischer Hilfe
umgehen dann sind sie natürlich auch
interessiert daran Waffen nicht nur aus
dem Iran und aus Nordkorea zu bekommen
sondern auch Waffen Nachschub aus China
und vielleicht ist auch ein Thema
wie könnte dann eine Resolution des
UN-Sicherheitsrates aussehen die von
China mit unterstützt wird womit
Russland dann wieder sagen in die
offensiv also moralische offensive oder
propagandistische Offensive käme um zu
sagen so könnte denn aus russisch
chinesischer Sicht ein Frieden aussehen
also was würden die Chinesen eigentlich
unterstützen wenn da eine
un-sicherheitsratsresolution vorbereitet
wurde ich vermute das ist sind die
Themen gewesen
wir gucken mit beiden Augen nach Moskau
das war zumindest der stand gestern
Abend als wir erfahren haben dass dort
eben diese Rewe gehalten werden soll in
wenigen Minuten aber ein Auge müssen wir
ja jetzt eigentlich Richtung Washington
mal richten denn der Präsident der
Ukraine ist zu seiner ersten
Auslandsreise seit Beginn des Krieges
aufgebrochen und zwar in die USA und der
wird dort US-Präsident beiden Treffen
der hatte schon in der Nacht verkünden
lassen über einen seiner Sprecher dass
man z.B das Patriot System in die
Ukraine liefern will ist das noch mal
alles ein neustadium des Eingreifens der
USA in diesem Konflikt wenn auch nicht
mit Soldaten aber mit Unterstützung
ich glaube es gibt eine große Unruhe in
der Ukraine beim ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski wie lange sagen die
Unterstützung der USA für seinen Kurs
hält und insofern fährt er dahin um
sowohl die beiden Administrationen auch
den Kongress einzustellen ihr müsst hier
lange Durchhaltefähigkeit
demonstrieren das heißt also uns auch
ermöglichen noch erhebliches Territorium
zurückzuerobern und zwar sowohl am
Schwarzen Meer am Asowschen Meer
möglicherweise auch die Landbrücke zur
Krim wieder zurück zu erobern
möglicherweise auch Angriffe auf
russischem Territorium durchführen zu
können wenn allein dies zu der Botschaft
bei der Putin führt ich kann den Krieg
nicht gewinnen und angesichts der
eskalationsbereitschaft in Russland von
der die Ukraine sehr ausgehen inklusive
der Option einer Winteroffensive wollen
die Ukraine sich versichern
sie nicht gedrängt werden jetzt einen
Kompromiss zu machen und zwar weil die
Amerikaner selber Probleme mit Waffen
Nachschub bekommen oder andere
NATO-Staaten auch sehen wenn wir das
hochrechnen was wir den letzten zehn
Monaten geliefert haben dann kommen wir
ans Ende der Fahnenstange das heißt
unsere Durchhaltefähigkeit ist sowohl
militärisch wirtschaftlich finanziell
aber auch politisch begrenzt und ich
glaube das wird das große Thema sein wie
lange auf welche Zeiträume müssen wir
uns einstellen und es gibt ja stimmen
durchaus auch im Pentagon die sagen wir
müssen uns letztlich hier auf einen
Kompromiss hinbewegen das heißt die
Ukraine in eine positive
Verhandlungsposition bringen aber nicht
mehr das Ziel unterstützen Rückkehr zum
Status Quo vor dem 24 Februar
das